all good things must come to an end but
some good things come to an end more
than once these TV shows ended up on the
chopping block multiple times
taxi premiered on ABC all the way back
in 1978 featuring a cast of current and
future stars of the late 70s and early
80s as a collective of New York City
taxi drivers the show starred the likes
of Judd Hirsch Danny DeVito Christopher
Lloyd Tony Danza Mary Lou Henner and
Andy Kaufman in hindsight the show
seemed too big to fail and in reality it
actually was too big to fail taxi ran
for Four Seasons until 1982 racking up
Amy wins and nominations and becoming
one of ABC's biggest commercial
successes it seems ludicrous that ABC
would ever cancel the program which was
a sentiment echoed at the time with
Creator James L Brooks telling the
Washington Post the one thing that's
clear from this is that the network is
saying to everybody don't think Emmys
will do you any good when it comes to
scheduling
after HBO declined to pick up the series
NBC came to the rescue restoring taxi to
its original time slot of Thursday
nights following their hit sitcom cheers
sadly the ratings failed to live up to
NBC's expectations resulting in its
second cancellation after only one
additional season in 1983. however most
of the cast got to briefly reunite to
film reenactments of Taxi scenes with
Jim Carrey when the comedian starred in
the 1999 biopic man on the moon as Andy
Kaufman most television audiences became
aware of Cagney and Lacey as a police
procedural that aired from 1982 to 1988
on CBS starring Sharon glass and Tyne
Daly as detectives juggling their
complex personal lives with crime
solving in New York City however most
people only know its resurrected state
it originally debuted as a pilot in 1981
starring Loretta Swit in the role of
Cagney alongside Daley while Meg Foster
took over the role when it was ordered
to a sixth episode for season in 1982
following the Show's first season CBS
pulled it from their lineup citing poor
ratings in audiences not connecting with
the two characters as aggression this
decision by the network resulted in
backlash from audiences while the show's
executive producer Barney rosenzweck
tried to renegotiate to get the show put
back on the air their compromise was to
recast Foster with Sharon glass who was
previously the first choice to play
Cagney the second season premiered to a
rocky start with the show getting
canceled for a second time in 1983 but
fan outcry eventually got it picked up
for a third season which sought receive
a boost in the ratings glass and Daly
proved to be a dynamic on-screen Duo
resulting in the show lasting another
Four Seasons before CBS canceled it for
good in 1988 after a ratings declined
leaving its season 7 Cliffhanger
unresolved although a rebooted pilot in
2018 couldn't get off the ground at CBS
the show did see four TV movies since
its cancellation
hard to believe that a show like
Baywatch which continues to hold the
record for the largest TV audience of
all time ever struggled to grab the
attention of audiences
premiering on NBC in 1989 the show
starred in ensemble cast featuring David
Hasselhoff and Pamela Anderson who would
go on to become some of the biggest
celebrities of the 1990s however after
its first season aired NBC quickly put
it to bed due to poor ratings and
reviews however its reruns in countries
like Germany and the UK save the show as
Broadcasting Company lbs Communications
revived Baywatch in 1991. Baywatch
continued to air in its original form
for 10 additional season throughout the
90s after its ninth season in 1999 the
show was restructured recast relocated
to Hawaii and rebranded as Baywatch
Hawaii to save costs as one would expect
the massive overhaul of Baywatch Hawaii
didn't sit well with audiences at the
time with the show facing a steep
decline in ratings until it was canceled
in 2001 after 11 Seasons however the
Baywatch brand has lived on through
spin-off series the 2003 film as well as
a 2017 film starring Dwayne Johnson Zac
Efron and Alexandra Daddario that was
panned by reviewers for many of the same
reasons the original Baywatch series
never garnered critical Acclaim the
truth is out there
but so are lies The X-Files was a game
changer for science fiction television
becoming one of the first shows of the
1990s to gain a cult fan base through
the early internet starring David
Duchovny and Jillian Anderson as FBI
agents investigating paranormal
occurrences The X-Files premiered on Fox
in 1993 and quickly Rose to become the
cult phenomenon that it currently is
however the show didn't maintain its
well-deserved praise forever the ninth
season of The X-Files which aired
between 2001 and 2002 was victim to a
drop in ratings in poor reviews from
television critics who cited the series
as lackluster riding compared to its
earlier more inspired seasons Fox pulled
the plug on the series though its
creator Chris Carter blamed the series
as cancellation on audience's
unwillingness to watch a show about
conspiracies and corruption in the wake
of the September 11 terrorist attacks
telling Gizmodo there was lots more we
could have done but we ended at the
right time to the Delight of many
hardcore fans Fox gave the X-Files a
second chance in 2016. Reviving it for a
10th season with dakovny and Anderson
returning the two actors also returned
for an 11th season but following its
conclusion Anderson officially parted
ways with the show this brought the
series to a premature end for a second
time as the creators currently have no
intention to continue on without Dana
Scully seventh heaven was a late hit of
the 1990s premiering in 1996 the series
which centers on a Protestant family
living in California with seven kids of
varying ages quickly became a hit on the
WB Network however the series was
subject to network shakeups in 2006
after the WB which shut down during a
merger with the United Paramount Network
to form a new channel the CW during the
change the WB canceled 7th Heaven after
10 seasons mostly due to the series's
high production costs and dwindling
ratings compared to the wb's other
series like Gilmore Girls and Smallville
additionally some of the show's biggest
stars such as Jessica Beale and Barry
Watson had left the show in its later
seasons and were unlikely to return
however once the rating spiked following
the announcement of the show's ending
the CW made the surprising decision to
pick 7th Heaven back up for an 11th
season to seize on the opportunity
sadly this decision didn't last long at
the CW the series was once again
canceled by the network in 2007 after
the end of the season even the show's
cast members have shot down recent
queries about a possible Revival as
recently as 2023 due to controversies
among some of the other cast members
Matt Greening is best known as the
co-creator of The Simpsons the
simultaneous longest-running animated
series and American sitcom on television
however he also garnered a cult fan base
for his second animated series Futurama
which premiered in 1999 on Fox Futurama
centers on Philip J fry a pizza delivery
man who has mistakenly cryogenically
frozen and reawakens a thousand years
later where he's hired by an
Intergalactic delivery company alongside
an eccentric Ensemble of characters
compared to the Simpsons the lifespan of
Futurama on Fox was short-lived due to
its inconsistent Air Time resulting in
its cancellation in 2002. yes I'm afraid
the brainless drones who run the net
worth canceled our license it wasn't
until years later after the show had
gained a second life through syndicated
reruns and four direct-to-video movies
that Futurama was picked up for its
Fifth Season by Comedy Central who
continued to air it for an additional
two seasons after that however the show
was never on Solid Ground uncommon
Central producing several possible
series finales until 2013 when its
actual finale meanwhile aired on the
network
until recently Futurama was thought to
be long dead but the impossible happened
in 2022 when Hulu ordered a Revival of
the series to air on their streaming
service however this revival news came
with controversy after voice actor John
DiMaggio threatened to not reprise his
role as Bender without a pay raise for
the entire cast fortunately once a new
deal was worked out DiMaggio did end up
returning
Family Guy was the brainchild of voice
actor Seth MacFarlane centering on the
Rhode island-based Griffin family and
their various Antics its first season
was subject to good ratings in 1999 but
when its second season saw a decline in
2000 Fox abruptly canceled the show only
to revive it for a third season a few
months later once Family Guy struggled
to maintain high ratings for its third
season Fox canceled it yet again in 2002
and sold the rights to Cartoon Network
who began airing reruns of the program
on their late night Adult Swim
programming block it slowly gained more
attention from Adult Swim's audiences
and thanks to the additional sales of
DVDs Family Guy was revived by Fox for a
second time in 2004. thankfully
McFarland kept an optimistic Outlook
about the show's ups and downs telling
the Calgary Sun we really wanted to keep
the show exactly as it was since its
fourth season return in 2005 Family Guy
has remained a staple of the Fox network
and a consistent success as of 2023
Family Guy has aired a total of 21
seasons and McFarland has remained a
part of the show's voice cast
debuting on ABC in 2001 scrubs start
Zach Braff as JD the daydreaming medical
intern at Sacred Heart Hospital who
Pines for his fellow intern Elliot Reed
played by Sarah chai the show's early
seasons were beloved by critics and fans
alike with Entertainment Weekly saying
of it in 2006 a likable Daffy buoyant
series that would be a big annoying mess
if it weren't done just right scrubs is
the very definition of nimble however
scrubs hit a brick wall when the
writer's Guild of America went on strike
from 2007 to 2008 shortchanging its
seventh season by seven episodes and
ultimately dooming it to cancellation
due to production being stalled after a
period of not knowing if scrubs would
continue airing ABC picked the show up
for its eighth season while this would
be seen as a victory by some it would
soon become Bittersweet when it was
announced that Braff intended to depart
from the show's main cast at the end of
the season sometimes when you get what
you want
you end up missing what you left behind
scrubs return for its ninth season in
2009 featuring a predominantly new cast
of medical students at Winston
University though braf appeared in six
of The Season's 13 episodes fans were
adamantly opposed to the vast changes in
the show's formula eventually ABC
announced that scrubs was canceled in
2010 with Brad telling his Facebook
followers it was worth a try but alas it
didn't work
thankfully the world of internet meme
culture has kept Arrested Development
alive longer than any network could
created by Mitch hurwitz Arrested
Development premiered on Fox in 2003 led
by Jason Bateman's Michael Bluth the son
of a corrupt real estate developer who
struggles to keep his family of
narcissistic delusional and financially
struggling socialites together the show
boasted one of the strongest ensembles
in TV history including David Cross Will
Arnett and Jessica Walter as well as
up-and-comers Aaliyah shakat and Michael
Sarah after three seasons of low ratings
on Fox Arrested Development was canceled
by the network but hurwitz was
determined to find his second home for
the series I don't think the home
builders organization is going to be
supporting us yeah the HBO is not going
to want us what do we do now well I
think it's showtime at after years of
failed starts and rumors of a film a
Arrested Development was finally revived
by Netflix which aired a fourth season
in 2013 featuring the entire returning
cast
however due to the conflicting schedules
of the show's cast the season was
structured to make each episode focus on
an individual character with plot lines
intersecting throughout the episodes
Arrested Development remained dormant
for many more years after the divisive
fourth season it wasn't until 2018 that
the show finally returned for the first
half of its fifth season with the second
half released in 2019 by this point
tensions off screen became tiresome for
the cast including an incident of
Jeffrey tambor's abusive onset behavior
that mixed with the unfortunate passing
of Walter in 2021 means that Arrested
Development is probably gone for good
although Community captured a dedicated
fan base from its very first episode
behind the scenes the show struggled to
stay on the air the NBC sitcom premiered
in 2009 starring Joel McHale as an
ex-lawyer forced to attend Community
College where he befriends a study group
of Misfits and outcasts and an ensemble
including Gillian Jacobs Alison Brie
Donald Glover and Chevy Chase the show
was created by Future Rick and Morty
co-creator Dan Harmon who was the main
catalyst for the show's off-screen
troubles
after a public Feud with Chase over
disagreements with the show's Direction
Armin was fired from season four of
community only to be rehired after Chase
himself left the show Harman returned
for season five of community but by that
point it was too little too late and
Community found itself on NBC's chopping
block in 2014. however after adopting
the tagline six seasons in a movie from
a previous episode fans were determined
to find the sitcom a new home Community
founded Saving Grace in Yahoo screen
which ordered a sixth season of the show
though by this point both Glover and
Yvette Nicole Brown had departed from
the cast with others eyeing their post
Community Futures although some involved
insisted that Community was not canceled
Yahoo screen shut down in 2016. Canning
the series's future to the Delight of
all Community fans the long-awaited
movie was finally confirmed in 2022 to
be happening Cougar Town marked a
triumphant return to the sitcom format
for Courtney Cox Who Rose to Fame by
playing Monica on NBC's friends from
1994 to 2004. on Cougar Town Cox plays
Jules a recent divorcee re-exploring
dating in her 40s with an ensemble of
her friends played by Dan bird Busy
Phillips and Krista Miller the show
premiered on ABC in 2009 though faced
many setbacks in its run including
producers requesting a name change its
biggest setback however came after the
third season when ABC removed it from
their mid-season schedule priming the
producers for a potential cancellation
the these predictions came to fruition
but Cougar Town was thankfully saved by
TBS who picked it up for a fourth season
in 2013 and then subsequently renewed it
for a fifth and sixth season I honestly
thought we might never be in this
kitchen again I'm just hanging out
telling our stories to each other
to the world sadly for fans of the
single camera sitcom TBS opted to end
its renewals after the sixth season
rendering that the final season of
Cougar Town after it finished airing in
2015. though the show was more prepared
than most for its series finale that
doesn't mean the cast wasn't
disappointed that the show wouldn't
continue on TBS as Josh Hopkins who
played Grayson in the show told variety
I'm going to miss seeing those people
every day but I just think what a great
experience it was rather than be sad
that it's over Nashville premiered on
ABC in 2012. centering on Hayden
Panettiere as a rising country star
named Juliet Barnes who threatens the
power of Connie Britton's Rayna James
the biggest draw to Nashville naturally
was its music the show included original
songs and covers that were distributed
by big machine records the same
Nashville label that formerly supported
Taylor Swift's rise to Country stardom
in the early 2000s sadly Nashville was
abruptly canceled by ABC after its
fourth season the announcement came
shortly after ABC confirmed that the
show would be Herald by new showrunners
which meant that it would be renewed for
a fifth season however the renewal
didn't come very quickly so the show's
fans resorted to an online campaign to
bring the show back to life after many
were disappointed at where the fourth
season left the series off the show was
revived on the CMT Network in 2016. a
more than appropriate home for the show
season 5 of Nashville premiered in 2016
but fans were even more shocked by the
series's turn of events which saw Connie
Britton's character killed off in the
first half of the Season though the show
was renewed for a final sixth season
which aired in 2018
cemt opted to not keep it going beyond
that point the future seemed hopeful for
a designated Survivor when it began
starring Kiefer Sutherland as a man
designated as next in line for the U.S
presidency after a terrorist attack
kills everybody ahead of him in the line
of succession the show premiered in 2016
on ABC with lots of net work support
behind it rather than have a pilot
ordered like most shows typically do
designated Survivor was ordered straight
to Ceres and was renewed for a second
season within a week of its first season
finale airing however in a business
decision almost as jarring as the show's
initial order ABC abruptly canceled
designated Survivor in 2018 after a high
turnover of showrunners in difficult
production scheduling failed to meet the
Network's expectations
however Netflix opted to renew the show
for a third season themselves as they
had already handled the distribution of
designated Survivor to International
markets following its third season
Netflix ultimately made the decision to
not renew designated Survivor any
further with the company thanking
Sutherland and their crew for creating a
satisfying final season designated
Survivor wasn't lucky enough to be
revived to be on the second chance that
Netflix gave it well I really screwed
that up didn't I however most fans of
the series are more than satisfied with
how it ended as far as Network science
fiction television shows go Timeless had
quite an interesting premise focusing on
a trio traveling through time to stop a
terrorist organization from altering
historical events Timeless was
eventually canceled by the network after
the end of its first season Timeless
sadly suffered from poor ratings during
its run on NBC fans clamored for the
show to be revived by another network
but to the surprise of the series as
creators Timeless was renewed three days
later by NBC themselves albeit with a
downsized episode order at only 10
episodes however this revival didn't
last long as NBC canceled the show yet
again in 2018 after the second season
ended this time around Timeless fans
didn't have to wait too long to see the
series properly conclude in their second
change of mind NBC ordered a two-part
finale to wrap up the series airing as a
Christmas special in 2018 and featuring
the time traveling Trio rewinding to the
hung Nam evacuation during the Korean
War which occurred during Christmas
1950. thankfully this two-part finale
was more than enough for fans to say
goodbye to the series that ran longer
than NBC wanted it to
hello